[Music]
dee
render feeder form a 4
rsa is inside diffusion 4 siger mars
tran
fighting game
8 Well, what was your idea to incorporate these 4 works into one game
? Hi That work is
the 50th anniversary of that very famous magazine in Japan, Weekly Shonen Jump.
This as to read e re re Shonen jsa is
a game once every 50 years, so I wanted to give everyone a great surprise.
4 aps 2 people ds a game Otsu
want to bring surprise 4 sapr early
boober first push Audi a pei puffer row r auto
with to do
nik sc another piece was the blues rear  Game
Hollywood 4 as for monder Crossover Wizard
Freshers
Once the balance,
my impression is that the past work is a bit like the game,
but in this work,
how to secure it?
Where is the differentiation of this game taken while there are similar titles? High Anoma In
terms of the differentiation point of this work
, it will be a competition of superheroes this time, so
switch the winter character  I think that the original part of this
game is to connect the combos one after another or to use the character to do the combo of the other party oreno
pearl deskstar feature destra Barostar 4 Wi prefecture ja
Arkan border
friend ur character sanders  Super Heroes A
4  r Ah lady minutes to do Words
dare to do ui is a shaved batting back to do.
I wonder if it can be done by connecting it together, or
do you have a system like that?
Well, the feature of this work is that the
physical strength gauge hit point part is one, so switch which character to switch.
Well, I will fight with the rules in one side
+ ode to do on 4th birthday sonor this
thing House power
I
'm making it to the present so that it's easy to switch to that part-time job so often that I want you to enjoy that combo casually and co-starring
refuse 2 way zone 1 a 4 a lenders
fu do do s 4 d cad When is the power mode in Dubai? I hope
that all the
players
can find and enjoy this dream combo that is unique to them and that various characters co-star.
I think
rapper krea fury
enjoy a make to do
that
ender ender former former rain 4 ae Audi a
porter Toro Susume Raber Haag
[ __ ] produced web etc. Play game 4
New user Fighting game or possible fighter for the
first time  I
've devised something so that people who are doing it can get in more quickly. Well,
for example, if there are 10 combos, there are such places
.
I'm making a game with a balance that makes me feel really good just by pressing that Kitasako button
four 4 ara t  omoa pondenn bar ber Designed beautiful music searcher
se
por 0 + pon vinegar Mars tamasen c chasm Women's
app is eno Screen
After that, even those first-time players can't keep doing it unilaterally.
What's more,
even if you've been receiving that combo for a long time, you can reset it once in the form of an emergency avoidance,
and the studios will change more and more.
Overworld Porters
Fatalby border Artillery 2
Precure Conveyor up to doing
Burger is also in front of 3 days at 3 parking not be 00 es and
Puretion Follower Winterwear
2 way to do with
Sei Duo 1 Can  Yes
[Music]
voodoo
Green Plaza voodoo Day about the brown Swing
sliding board rear road to do for Mantilose Bar
shop in time bagus place ani With pipe Wood brown to do
with pain Poly are you
about to do is our mixed line to do
Prabolua uranos  pou dou dou It's a
functional story, but when
it comes to power from the city of Goku, it's
unique, but how do you balance it in the game with such various powers
?  And in
that, what do you call that character? How do you have a hard time keeping your mind?
Well, in terms of the balance this time, for example, if you do that extreme balance, the
customer will have a pleasant battle.  I don't think it can be done, so it
's a
rule to some extent. Any character will fight in the direction.
Charge key polymer
wii Down character  On top of that, for example, I'm thinking
about the performance of the special move, or the performance of the character, and the action of the character such as graphics
.
e erg Inter is witch rr Durer
Dual action Suo Brafix
voodoo
to this superb Good ben
to do Stargee Dragon Ball Fighters etc.
By the way,
regarding Death Note, how is it devised in the process of weaving it into such a national fighting game? Well, it
's a
battle action game of this work,
but it's not just fighting, it's the
reality and the world of cartoons.  It is
a work with a world view that superheroes such as Ahn Super Goku and Rufianal confront the enemy of the fusion
of Akushun Filing a.
vertex
please
Broader sexteen Way
Onma time sorry Half number Sky
roof filing end Broader we are n
Filing hospital spender Willow time
There is also an element in which customers can enjoy the story
.
The note is not the character of that battle, but the character that is
entwined with the
story. Play this game feature story w
Dou Play Feast Luer Chaude Story
Diz b vend stories Wood fc
Yeah filing char type saks easy
knee cn story big
whirlpool tf est rosel story 6 o
wall ares big booing fa
amenco sby rater enodeb 2 story brings 5i
the voodoo
story mode
-When I see it, I really care about the story because it feels like the world of anime and manga is in the real world, but I
don't know how much I can say, but what kind of story is it?  But
yeah, I'm sorry there, I can't tell the details of that story yet,
but yeah, I think
that traders are facing Goku and
Luffy.  But after
all, Death Note has a slightly different look at it from a bird's-eye view,
so it
's
just a matter of simply fighting the enemy.
I hope everyone can look forward to imagining and waiting for it to be entwined like this.
Chong Chong Story Ah
Wiper
gere We view 2 more Air Azison A little whitening is eaten by Face
Art Gens Freezer.
In the month issue that shakes s + na ah ah
by san Week beer 2nd outbound trip I have to
go Sensei ods Action pine game by
end profile to increase production tests for n one Increased
taste is 3 darts
ran Otsu also mo ru powder  instr Star
Pork Loin e to serve as wedding 4 s power to
do
render b Sports Pleasures Sofa Hahe
war sore to do is Version Jabber se Pink Movie
There are various works in it because it's the 50th anniversary of the story.
Until then, I've been watching those 3 titles, but what
kind of titles will come out from now on? First of all, my eldest daughter will buy it.
Everyone got a lot of excitement in the public announcement, so
I will give you information that this new work will participate in the war again before the heat of everyone
cools down, so I hope you can expect it in the future.  duca me  Le
Order Grab ah
b e 3
adiva Spring hype I heard that Yes part ob Labora
This kind of rough estimate 2 Machisova before I'm in the middle
Pamu sender er the voodoo
go ran den den o Hour p Burger Laughing evil
Java kids aren Damn
nsr  Abyss Buddha thin manga by nuno fodendo 4 f
Nana indera soa Beijing condition render Carp red pressure
nog River serry guard deformer 3 awesome
pb usaeightohoh
web r heater hype opener belo belo
eros 4
[music]
voodoo
sd car
aso render Arles er A Fire legs are Kurosaki
Fes
me
ro ra se n Away 4 Spec Bar Power Star Works rs
energ points you do Otsu
and his work Well, moving from the world of manga and anime to the real world of songs.
It was the most difficult part of changing to that kind of expression.
How was the challenge part
? Well, that Poon or the expression of anime manga is a two-dimensional
expression, so that's it.  When you bring it to 3d realistically,
that white, for example, the texture of Goku's manga,
the material, and the material of the Rufino manga, are
well in the school
game.  I'm making it while setting that image
Tsugiya
voodoo 2 d
Charlie Garden Total Timor buster Orb you do s 4 s One
Fighter Recording Up Forever Gua Dua
Walk yn Blogger Witcher 23 Ma gen
Head Enchanter
Maker Harp n In the game
, it's in progress right now, and I'm improving the quality from now on,
but
what kind of character's facial part facial and various expressions are made  The expression of time
Well
, I think it's getting better and better now, well in this time, I think it's the hardest thing to do.
Black Aqua j version 4 spero s fashion ad has an
energy
jab station rate 0
high
This time I am very happy to announce that jump force to everyone at this e 3 place
that br are bad to do John 4  star is good,
but this time I'm opening a store, but it's still under development,
so there are
some elements that aren't included in the game yet, so I think everyone
will have a chance to play again in the future.  I want you to ace expectations there as
well.
Ah
, it's zero with insects, so in the morning, a building,
which work you are paying attention to most, which character will participate, will be released
more and more in the future, so please imagine something and wait.  I
'm glad if you get it.
s we are the bag
for search